nuclear weapons in the hands of
fanatical religious people who think
that the day of judgement is around the
corner I think for for people to
understand it they should probably see
pictures of Hiroshima and Nagasaki and
that was pretty much a primitive bomb
the bombs that they are trying to make
now have far more advanced and conclude
far more people and with consequences
for decades for the places that are that
will be affected but someone like
mahmoud ahmadinejad the current
president of iran has made it very clear
that he is able he's willing and he's
able to acquire that bomb and he's going
to use it he has declared war on the
State of Israel when the leader of one
country tells the leader of another
country I'm going to wipe you off the
map that according to international
relations is a declaration of war ever
since he came to power he made it very
clear pretty much like Hitler when he
came to power that he was going in that
direction now the first reaction was
understandable where you see we should
negotiate this man let's understand what
he wants to say let's talk to him let's
use sanctions and so on but you always
have to have that military option of the
option of force on the table and my
criticism on the european union
leadership is that that is off the table
yes he has made it very clear that he's
going to use it and and not only that he
is already financing and disrupting and
the US policy and Western policy in the
Middle East and he's trying to become a
very dominant in that region and so he
is someone who's very much he's very
self-assured because the usual mode of
that one you know deterring someone from
doing something which are always
material and worldly things he doesn't
believe in he welcomes death and in that
region it's not that I'm not saying that
everyone there believes that but
part of the radical Islamic doctrine is
to believe that things will be better in
the Hereafter so people welcomed death
not all of them but many of them and
those engaged in that welcomed death
which means the old forms of of
deterring people from doing things such
as acquiring a bomb or using it but the
old methods the sanctions and so on
that's not something that's going to
make any impression on them I think if
we go back to as far as the tenth and
eleventh centuries and when according to
the history books the West was backward
and Islam the Islamic world was far more
progressive that one thing that changed
was Europeans that was the West then and
went off and traveled towards the
Islamic world with China and Japan and
started to observe the way these people
lived and thought that by doing that
they could learn something from them and
they came back with those lessons and
they innovated at the same time that
they were challenging their own
institutions such as the church then
later the printing press came and all
these forces came together where it was
the desire to learn from the outside and
the challenge of the feudal institutions
within that were closing the mines
within the West it's around that time
that in the Arab Islamic empire that's
what it was and there was a conviction
that they had nothing to learn from the
past from others that all knowledge was
sort of concentrated into the Quran and
that we were leading in everything so
there was this lacks this attitude that
all knowledge is something we have we
can't learn anything from the west and I
think that that's when the divergence
started and those minds on the eastern
side closed and the Western
opened and innovated and progressed at
this piece that was so breathtaking for
for the Arab Islamic world that by the
time they actually woke up to their
backwardness the West was so far ahead
in military political religious cultural
and social progress that this I mean all
we can do now is copy it's very little
left to invent I'm optimistic about the
fact that there are several individuals
by far not the majority who have been in
touch with the West with Asia with other
non Islamic cultures and who realized
that there's a lot that we have to learn
my optimism is that that group will be
influential enough to make the reforms
and the changes necessary in that part
of a world second observation is you
cannot change if you do not accept that
there is something to change that is
something imperfect so the dogma that
everything in Islam and the moral
framework that the Prophet Muhammad left
for us is perfect and that there is
nothing to change in that that is being
challenged because of that challenge a
natural reaction is one of defending it
with all the fanaticism in the group in
the community that can lead to bloodshed
we also live in circumstances where
people like Ahmadinejad who is a
fanatical Muslim has nuclear power is at
least aspiring towards getting one
Pakistan has one Egypt wants one turkey
wants one under those circumstances if
they succeed in acquiring these weapons
of mass destruction then we are facing
we're facing terrible times meaning if
you look at the Western evolution
towards modernity and the progress that
we have reached now those weapons were
not there there were mass matters
there were genocides there were lots of
you know all the atrocities that human
beings do to each other but having
nuclear weapons just makes things so
much more drop more dramatic and you
know it's not it's not easy times that's
the very pessimistic and what most
urgent the thing that we need to look at
now another observation is if you look
at all the conflicts in the world today
you will be surprised by the number of
Muslims and tangled in conflict among
themselves with China with pressure with
the West we are only one-fifth of the
world population having so many enemies
all at the same time it's very
self-destructive now if the fanaticism
within the Muslim world that is now
being fed by the fact that if we die the
hereafter is going to be a better place
then it's very difficult to stop that
but if that is diluted and I always like
to see the couples have full that there
will be voices and that they will be
strong enough to say it's madness to
commit to kill and to be killed because
of this belief in the hereafter and make
the belief in the hereafter relative and
then things could look better but on the
very short time it looks like things
will look bad I think the major
misperception in the Western world on
Islam is that it's equal to peace and
that it can be reconciled with liberal
democracy the fanaticism within Islam
and its basic tenets is something that's
underestimated in the West and I think
that Western leaders political
intellectual religious leaders the
sooner they recognize that that faith
the Islamic faith needs to go through a
process of
information and enlightenment and that
it's going to come at a very high price
the better the sooner they do that to
the better as long as these leaders go
around seeing Islam is peace that is I
think that major misconceptions also a
very self-destructive one I think we
should make a distinction between Islam
and Muslims what I'm trying to do is to
say all over the world we can identify
with each other as human beings that is
the basic glue the fact that you're an
individual human being and I'm an
individual human being that's what's
that's where our common commonality of
common strength lies in and common
interest Islam if we view it as one of
the philosophies of political theories
or ideas produced by human beings
throughout history just one of them and
view it scrutinize it criticize it as we
have done with all other doctrines
religious or secular then we may be able
from the west now using realizing
someone who's westernized convince
Muslims to make a different choice and
to reform their faith fast by
acknowledging that there are things
wrong with their faith so our goal
should not be to be to preserve Islam
our goal should be the common human you
know we are we are human so Muslims are
humans they are not fast mule born just
as a baby in Pakistan or in Saudi Arabia
or in Yemen or in a Muslim community
here if we emphasize that then I think
we can make that change and that
involves two things that involves
learning to distinguish between who is
an enemy and who is a friend but before
you decide who is an enemy and who is a
friend you yourself have to decide what
do you stand for what are your own set
of ideas that you feel as superior to
that of Islam and are you willing to
defend and die for your own
ideas of freedom and humanity and
humanism as much as the fanatics are
willing to die for their own I think
that's such a good question because it
puts it just shows how experimental it
all was a process of trial and error and
it's still the case for instance and
this is a point of criticism there's no
consensus in the United States on who
the enemy is whether to really say it's
Islam or it's a perversion of a form of
Islam's it will have ism Salafis amor is
it basic Islam who should we ally with
strategically in other words the
approach has been very much strategic
there are people in the united states
including this administration who are
waking up to the fact that it is there
is a battle of ideas going on but they
are too shy to voice what the ideas are
another point of criticism and that's
not only towards this administration but
I've seen hide it all over the place is
just is this desire to avoid Saudi
Arabia as a culprit of you know the
state that's not only financing
terrorism but also financing the
ideology behind the terror acts I think
it was a mistake to declare a war on
terror terror is just a tactic it shows
how much how strategic the whole
approach is towards what's going on
another mistake both on both sides of
the Atlantic is that if we just
appeasement if you just understand what
they want from us and we give it to them
they might not be so so bad to us so
they might forego the mites I think
those are mistakes that were made but
again i'll come back to the distinction
between the European America and it
seems as if America is learning much
faster than Europe and by learning I
mean waking up to the fact that it is
Islam not necessarily all Muslims but
Islam as I said
ideas and that that can mean military
mean very disastrous military action and
which is for every politician it is a
terrible decision to take to say we are
going to all we are going to do
something destructive or we're going to
take an unpopular action an American
seem to be much more courageous in
making that decision they did in the
steering the Second World War and later
then the Europeans who have I i think
the European leadership at the point at
this point is feel yourself destroying
and I say this because of the approach
to Iran